good morning gamers
welcome to the first ever live lawyer
say it with me live the way i want to
see the chat loud away
an historical moment humanity has led up
to this point
millions of years billions of years how
who knows how long time has gone
but it all comes down to this live
lawyer
at last now i'm doing this because i'm
really excited about it and not because
side couldn't edit today and
i didn't want to edit so i decided to do
live the y
it was destined it was destiny that
brought me here
and who knows how this is gonna go but
here we are
lovely boy anyway sorry we'll be back
next week i apologize
[Laughter]
roll the intro
is it working it got
what happened what happened
[ __ ] we got technical difficulties on
lively y
although i can fix this
there we go i asked you leave your
entries in the subreddit
was that it that's interest it's kind of
short
never realize how short the intro is
welcome everyone to live live
hope you're having a great day grab your
favorite g fuel cup
and let's just freaking do this all
right
hopefully no copyrighted material on
this one
bam bam
speaking of side no not again
pokemon single by the way cybe
i mean hi
wait i gotta switch to my reaction psy
stop it see i actually saw this already
and i have fired side
for simpery it's gone too far this is a
joke by the way i haven't
but uh now i'm considering it that's
also a joke
all right moving on
everyone in the chat cybe simp he needs
some support
he needs our group to help him
didn't didn't pokeman make a whole spiel
about other people caring about her
relationship status
and then that's creepy which i agree 100
but then go she's single single by the
way
anyway all right not edited let's keep
moving
day 306 oh wait i had background music
shoot
hold up live the y live the y oh
i don't know if you guys can hear this
but it makes me feel like drinking
some g fuel in the morning i don't know
about you guys but this makes me feel
like i'm
doing a lively y right now
i've never seen this many simple emojis
jesus christ
calm down day 364 of
and don't calm down lively why i have
successfully learned how to use the
enchantment table
god damn well done is that a freaking
scooter
combine that axe with that scooter and
you got a weapon of math
mass destruction right there i almost
said math destruction
amazing i don't want to
bump into that guy let me just tell you
that
yes yes yes if you ever die in minecraft
world in this minecraft world don't say
it in the title
just let us be surprised unpopular
opinion
all right i guess not
uh sure fine if that's what you want
lively y confirmed i
you can clip this it's probably gonna
get a couple billion views but uh yes
okay
i will say yes to this t-series
hitting are we doing this i'm scared
okay
all right teaser is hitting pewdiepie on
his way to huh
me who's 1 million steps away from 1
million subs
damn large linky well done lively why
i'm not logged in thanks for not showing
my email at least
lively why anything can happen think
about the possibilities
of me doxxing myself this is great
[ __ ] i hate this come back scythe i need
you this sucks
next one how much is a ten dollar i need
that calming music
this is too much for my heart um
dreamy gaming was oh yes
this feels like it's lively why
how much is a 10 uber ride how heavy is
the 10 kilogram one artificial
intelligence ai
yes i killed her but that doesn't prove
i'm innocent
so much knowledge so much wisdom on this
channel
people don't appreciate actually i like
his philosophy videos
pewdiepie is actually really smart
artificial intelligence ai
[Music]
oh all right listen up pause the [ __ ]
music
i am extreme hold up i am extremely
smart
okay there's a you have to understand
there's hundreds of thousands of
billions of footage of me online
saying dumb stuff this doesn't count
this doesn't mean anything what you
never said anything dumb
i don't think so delete this small pp of
course which i got damn it i didn't log
in
well i will log in later and i will give
it small pp
every 60 seconds in africa a minute
passes
such profound wisdom wow
huge brain ginormous
do an iq test i don't want to make y'all
feel bad
oh great is it the same joke what is it
called in english when i do a front flip
it's just called a front flip okay
listen in english i didn't know the word
okay in swedish swedish we call it
somersault when you flip
forward somersault it's not even summer
you dumbasses
you're dumb learn english next meme
small peepee
uh me watching it as my drawing of lola
bunny appears in pewdiepie video with my
logo removed lol
but it's a fan overlord i'm confused
it's okay don't do that don't crop that
means
small pp i finally beat hardcore mode
supporting fartsy and nice
that's so cute i love this fat art
that's so good like 80s anime yeah yeah
it is yeah
that's so cool who made this joey
cordero
6565 lively y
first fan art you have the privilege and
the honor and you've earned me
god damn well done sir you got a wise
live salute excellent
moving on this is too motivational this
music
i don't know if you can even hear it
it's probably really low
you requested six nine four twenty six
nine dollars from elon musk tesla and
now we wait
all right let us know on the update
[Music]
in the next live the y all videos live
now
all of them sorry sai sabzi this is
cyber right now
i realize i could be interpreted as
racist it's the expression of the face
so i've edited that out
pewds nobody has ever looked at a rock
and said hey i want to taste that the
person who discovered salt
salt is not a rock salt is not a rock
everyone knows this
everyone knows this delete and he called
me dumb
oh god it keeps going
what what did i say maybe we can
plant the egg i mean has anyone tried
yeah live the y next episode we'll plant
an egg and see what happens
bamboo freak yeah i can make shampoo
you've never
statistics show that teen pregnancy
drops off significantly
after age 25.
well this went through an editor do you
understand every magazine has an editor
that changes these so that's really dumb
i have an editor too but he's not here
today
so point proven when you can't find your
house in minecraft
is that tambourines hell yeah
[ __ ] yeah i'm sorry but the music is so
light for me but i think it's not that
loud for you and i should have checked
the levels before i'm confused
appears how heavy is 10 kilos europeans
haha what an idiot americans trying to
figure
it out it's 22 pounds
[ __ ]
how much is 10 kilos in
pounds oh
[Music]
look at this let's go
lively why let's go
yes
cheers gamers
we can drink g-fuel live now it's all
happening
salt is not a rock salt is not a rock
you can come in all you want
hey peels remember i'm not gonna play
all right i don't think that's how
headphones work
okay i gotta be quiet here right martha
doesn't care if
ken links to microphone lit what a
dumbass
cam leaned into the microphone to hear
and y'all call me stupid
what does that make him huh which is
heavier
a kilogram of steel or a kilogram
i don't get it listen listen listen
when i was post this question and i was
like
right out of the womb they wanted to
check me right away they knew
they saw my abnormally large brain and
they thought we gotta
ask him right away i nailed it
feathers are heavier it's a trick
question
gaming voice chat was invented in 1995
gamers in 1994. my dearest opponent
gg easy
[Music]
and you know what else oh sorry you know
what else they asked me
uh is is salt a rock
as soon as i was born they asked me that
and i say no you dumbass it's not a rock
it is yes
it is a mineral composed of primarily
primarily of sodium chlor
chloride nacl [ __ ]
that in a rock [ __ ] that's what i said
to the doctor
true story
condom
[Laughter]
condom pee pee folder hell yeah
live the y let's go
pewds accidentally word something wrong
this sub a core memory
yeah yeah
stop it hey
you guys are worse than mainstream media
trying to dig up everything i ever said
core pp like reveal at 10 million
oh [ __ ] for l live
why i will reveal my legs
[Music]
are you ready in the spirit of life the
wife
oh i'm too scared what if people judge
me
i don't know if this is a good idea
we start with the knees ah
okay
okay that's enough that's enough
that's enough stop it
maybe pears can do a viking x portal
design
it would look cool
that is cool that is cool i like it
looks like a lot of work i don't know
what
oh that's sweet yeah i i really like
that episode
and i saw uh i saw some of the people
that we made fun of were totally
like they weren't pissy about it which i
always appreciate because we're just
doing it for good fun
uh so that was cool the guy who still
hasn't refreshed or closed coco since it
released
youtube now this doesn't work and they
changed it it used to be a thing like
that
i don't know why i'm going into the
specifics like it matters just a [ __ ]
meme
but yeah you're wrong i'm right
they actually don't they don't know that
i actually gave up
a rick ashley meme that made me laugh oh
it could only be
live lawyer who would have thought
who would have thought how so how heavy
is the ten kilo one
the world you [ __ ] donkey americans
no no he's got a point yeah i was asking
for the americans
and i actually knew it was 22 pounds
because i use weights
[Music]
as you can tell by my giant legs
i mean arms anyway
where did you learn your english from me
this is kind of wholesome because uh
yeah i learned english
from like playing games online and [ __ ]
like that i used to be
terrible at it i remember i i joined a
like a [ __ ] ventrilo server once with
a bunch of strangers and everyone was
just babbling and they were like
why is uh pewdie so silent that i was
just like
[Music]
gotta i hello
call of duty anyone we play now okay
anyway that's cool good on you gamers
[Music]
this is uh audios i gotta pause all
right
oh is this macaroni with the chicken
strips
can you hear it better now maybe
macaroni
with the chicken strips
perfectly timed how do you only even get
that
[Music]
nice that's huge pp see
people people do the uh the end and city
and
minecraft for the end city and minecraft
for the
so i've added something here end city
for the elytra
and city for the enron so you can molest
your
villages
lime the y lime the y let's go
oh is it too loud now [ __ ]
hell yeah let's get it live the y
pewte's getting sucked into his own
automatic sorting system
i like it even it's on point with a
color scheme i love it well done
hey now that i'm doing lively y i can
ask you guys what the
where is this from i have no idea this
is a movie
i feel like i recognize it is it the
oompa loompas
is it the oompa loompas
you're being ex chocolate all right i
already knew
all right fine fine i already knew i
already knew stop answering
stop answering stop it stop it lil y oh
god
i thought it was bad enough when
comments answer but the live chat is
just 10 times worse oh my god
how i imagine pete's profile
hell yeah dude that's that's halloween
costume right there
sorted that's sick i like that big
peepee bald tussy nice
uh felix 2016 setup is hella sus
what what is it it's a bird
uh all right again i guess i'll have to
ask you guys what the [ __ ] is it
i mean i drew it it is a bird what am i
missing
a mangas a mogus it's a mogus
ah don't stop answering stop answering
stop answering
stop stop chat i already got the answer
no no no no no oh my god
you're so tired among us again
oh
oh my gosh
you probably pee in the shower don't you
no
also pewds he doesn't know i took a [ __ ]
in the shower
for those of you don't know yes i am i
had no choice but it had to be done
my anus had already made up its mind
it was written in stone just like live
lawyer was written in stone
i would do it again if i had to
i think everyone should try it at least
once
heck it let's do it next live the y what
do you guys say
you begin learning swedish and are
having a hard time understanding the
difference between
et and n yeah okay you realize you can
make a meme about it and ask for helix
yeah well the problem is that they it
makes no [ __ ] sense
so for those who don't know
uh annette is like
i how do i explain it it's like the
specifying an a thing or an object
but we use either n or it and some
languages have like female and male
i don't think that's what it is
uh it we just you just have to remember
it
i'm so glad i never had to learn swedish
because [ __ ] that
you realize you need uploads in order
for him to help you understand the
difference
all right you got there you google it
and a native swedish speaker said they
don't know the difference yeah
no one knows i think there used to be
rules
but it's gone so long that it's just
completely lost
you realize you can just post the meme
on reddit and get help from a swedish 19
year old
you realize that they might not know it
either you realize pewdiepie had no
[ __ ] clue either i apologize
i don't know the rules no one knows the
rules it's more advanced than the
minecraft
enchantment language gaming keyboards be
like
[Music]
i don't get it are they referring to
like
when you press down
i don't get i don't get it
help me chat for once you can help me
this is your chance chad
help wsd
that's funny i wouldn't have gotten it
without you hey thanks guys
that's a funny joke except if you have
the pewdiepie keyboard of course
of course wsd
are just um i don't know if you can see
but they're actually
um they got the pattern on them it feels
nice on your texture
link in description oh this is a perfect
time time for uh
sponsor segment sponsor eagle
uh we're gonna i don't i don't know if i
can show this but i'm gonna show it
because it's live the wine
we have these custom huh
so you don't need the pewdiepie keyboard
and it
has this cool box what's inside felix
custom brofist escape button
all right it's cool
say it's cool damn that's dope okay yeah
it is cool
it's like uh transparent you can't
really
see it i don't know how i'm going to
show it to you this is show better
can you see it good now you see it well
hold on
[ __ ] yeah ah now i gotta focus my
[ __ ] face
that's good enough [ __ ]
is that better yeah people and people
wonder why my quality is always so bad i
don't get it
we're selling 5000 of these check out my
instagram
if you're interested anyway sponsor
eagle out
live the y keep moving youtube i can
happen may when i first joined pewdiepie
submissions
i go to the y
and i never left because it's the
greatest reddit on the planet thank you
live the y i don't know why we call it
pewdiepie submissions it should really
be called the y
oh that's cute i decided to post the fan
art for the first time
and first time light blue y
incredible literally i'm scared i've
seen this a billion times get the [ __ ]
out of here
foods have literally helped me through
almost the entirety of 2020. i have been
fighting suicide and depression i
suffered heartache i lost my father all
in the span of three months
thanks for being there to get me through
and oh
felix i know you didn't see this oh god
that makes it worse
i'm sorry honestly
um i'm happy to be i don't know what to
call it a distraction maybe
or just uh someone to hang out with
because i feel you
sometimes if i'm feeling lonely i just
like to put on a video and i'm like oh
cool i put on my own videos actually i'm
like this guy is awesome
sorry i don't mean to meme this all the
best on keith
i'm just playing coco you know i love
you
all right that one slipped in i'm not
allowed to meet
uh live why anything can happen is that
a mother flipping pewdiepie reference
there's a brofist in the latest pokemon
anime
hell yeah oh lively wise the best
lively wife forever dantdm's world that
took him seven months to make pewdiepie
after
three months well
shaders look makes anything look good to
be fair
and i've also spent an ungodly amount of
time playing minecraft for the past
three months
uh and i'm sure dance looks great hey
gamers lively wisdom
now that the music is all holy and stuff
never build yourself up by tearing other
people down
lively
oh okay moving on
whoa whoa whoa whoa
[Music]
whoa
[Applause]
sit oh
oh i got a stream ended cool
hell yeah that's sick it's my barking
life of the y anything can happen
feuds natural clay putes sand extra
crunchy
[Music]
disgusting repulsive small peepee
get this out of my sight
[Laughter]
you've probably cleaned the shower down
she always appears i actually take the
[ __ ] in the shower
well gamers i think we're getting to
that time where the memes are just
repeating itself
like all good things in life they must
come to an end
this has been the one and only lively
why
thank you for watching smash like
subscribe
check out g-fuel and as always
uh the y
i'll end this with the ending stream
there you go thanks for joining live the
wide gas that was super fun
this song does not fit at all can we
have something funny
yeah yeah
[Music]
say with me chat i was there i was there
for lively y
i was witnessing history
brofist in the chat prophets in every
chat that were in the comment section
afterwards for the people that watch it
later
bye bye stay stay strong
and breakfast in the chat how do i end
it
it work